nos dicen que la función f es dos veces
diferenciable con f de 2 es igual a 1
efe prima de 2 es igual a 4 y f prima
prima de 2 es igual a 3 cuál es el valor
de la aproximación de f de 1.9 usando la
recta tangente de la gráfica de f en x
igualados pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo esta es una pregunta real de
un examen pasado de ap cálculo muy bien
hagámoslo juntos si realmente estuviera
haciendo esto en un examen simplemente
iría a lo más importante y me daría
cuenta de que la ecuación de la recta
tangente en x es lo mismo que pasar por
el punto 21 y luego averiguar ya cuál es
el valor de y cuando x es igual a 1.9 y
esa sería mi aproximación pero por el
bien del aprendizaje y de obtener la
intuición aquí asegurémonos de que
entendemos lo que está sucediendo así
que déjenme graficar esto digamos que
este es mi eje y
y luego éste es mi eje x
este es x1 éste es x igual a 2
este es igual a 1 sabemos que el punto
21 está en la gráfica de y es igual a fx
entonces sabemos que ese punto está ahí
y también conocemos la pendiente de la
recta tangente la pendiente de la recta
tangente es igual a 4 se va a ver como
algo así probablemente es un poco más
empinado que esto la pendiente de la
recta tangente se verá como algo así no
sabemos mucho más que esto conocemos la
segunda derivada pero lo que nos están
pidiendo que hagamos es que sin saber
cómo es realmente la función podría
verse más o menos así déjenme dibujar
algo entonces la función probablemente
se vea así estamos tratando de encontrar
cuánto es
efe de 1.9 así que si x es igual a 1.9
efe de 1.9 si así es como se ve la
función en realidad podría ser este
valor que tenemos aquí no estamos
seguros por qué
no sabemos mucho sobre la función pero
lo que nos están sugiriendo que hagamos
es que usemos esta recta tangente si
conocemos la ecuación de esta recta
tangente que tenemos aquí podríamos
decir bueno a que es igual esta recta
tangente cuando x es igual a 1.9 cuando
x es igual a 1.9 es igual a este punto
que tenemos aquí y luego podríamos usar
eso como nuestra aproximación para efe
de 1.9 bueno para hacer eso necesitamos
conocer la ecuación de la recta tangente
y podríamos hacer eso en forma de punto
pendiente sólo tendríamos que decir que
menos el valor de jake que conocemos en
esta recta
sabemos que el punto 21 está en esa
recta entonces que menos 1 va a ser
igual a la pendiente de nuestra recta
tangente la cual sabemos que es igual a
4 por x menos el valor de x que
corresponde a ese valor de g
así que x menos 2
así que ahora solo tenemos que sustituir
x igual a 1.9 para obtener nuestra
aproximación de f de 1.9 entonces
diremos que menos 1 es igual a 4 por 1.9
21.92 es igual a menos 0.1 y 4 por menos
0.1 todo esto se simplifica como menos
0.4 ahora sumamos 1 de cada lado y
obtenemos que es igual a 0.6 así que
esto no lo dibujé muy bien escala 0.6
podría ser algo más cercano a esto pero
ahí lo tienen esta es nuestra
aproximación para efe de 1.9 la cual es
la opción b y terminamos algo en lo que
nos tenemos que fijar es que no usamos
toda la información que nos dieron no
tenemos que usar esta información sobre
la segunda derivada para resolver el
problema
así que si alguna vez se encuentran en
esa situación no lo duden mucho porque a
veces nos dan información que no se
necesita
hasta el próximo vídeo